one person has been killed and several
others wounded in a shooting at
heidelberg university in southwestern
germany police say the assailant was an
18 year old german man with no previous
criminal record he opened fire inside a
lecture hall before turning the gun on
himself the motive for the attack is
still being investigated
a university town shaken by a violent
attack
just after noon an armed attacker
stormed a lecture hall on heidelberg's
university campus and started shooting
at students
leaving four people injured
the man then fled and killed himself
the 18 year old german suspect lived in
nearby mannheim
we have already searched his flat and
gathered evidence
what we've been able to verify so far is
that directly before the attack he sent
a whatsapp message to someone
in which he wrote that people now had to
be punished
one of his victims a 23 year old student
later died of her injuries in hospital
police say it appears the attacker had
bought his weapons abroad
germany's chancellor expressed shock at
the events
it breaks my heart to hear this news
my thoughts are with the relatives and
the victims
and of course with the students of the
university of heidelberg
the university is the oldest and most
prestigious in germany
university universities and the city of
heidelberg
should and will continue to be spaces
where people can move without fear
this is where science can prosper and
where young people can prepare for life
after months of distance learning due to
the pandemic students here had only
returned to in-person classes three
months ago
the joy of being back in lectures and
seminars now tainted by tragedy
dw stephanie burnett is in heidelberg at
the university where the shooting took
place hi stephanie do we know anything
at this point about the possible motive
of the perpetrator
the investigation is ongoing and the
police have not specified what the
motive is as far as we know it remains
unclear at this point what we do know
is that the suspect is an 18 year old
german man who is a student at the
university of heidelberg and he's
believed to have approached this
building behind me and attacked the
lecture hall as class was going on
police have said that it is not he is
not believed to have been a student of
that particular class though he is a
student at this university
he used one gun to attack the classroom
he also had another weapon on him police
found once they approached the suspect
after he killed himself
and what we also know is that it appears
that he bought the weapons from abroad
shortly before
carrying out this crime so these are
some of the major questions that
authorities will be looking into which
is how did he get access to gun and what
is the motive
and we mentioned one person has been
killed several others wounded what can
you tell us about the victims
not much information is coming out about
the victims what we do know is that one
female student at the age of 23 was
killed and three others were wounded but
so far we do not know any more details
about those who are currently wounded at
the moment
dw's stephanie burnett reporting there
on the very latest from heidelberg thank
you for that update stephanie